ihr seht vor mir die Zutaten für
Spaghetti Bolognese allerdings nicht für
ein Rezept sondern gleich für drei und
nicht irgendein Rezept oder nicht
irgendwelche Rezepte sondern die von
drei bekannten deutschen Köchen wir
haben einmal Frank Rosin einmal Steffen
Henssler und einmal Tim Mälzer bei Tim
Mälzer war ich ja letztens schon im
Restaurant bei den anderen beiden war
ich auch schon mal heute ist die Frage
wie gut sind ihre Rezepte dazu muss ich
sagen die Rezepte sind aus verschiedenen
Szenarien entnommen teilweise aus wo z.B
Frank Rosin jemanden im Restaurant hilft
Tim Mälzer hat das glaube ich auf einer
Website gemerkt schon unterschiedliche
Szenarien unterschiedliche Aufwand vor
allem unterschiedliche Zutaten deshalb
bewerten wir das ganze heute nach fünf
verschiedenen Kriterien und die
Kriterien sind Schwierigkeit Aufwand
dauerkosten und Geschmack in einen
Kriterien ist es möglich fünf Punkte zu
bekommen was eine Maximalpunktzahl von
25 bildet glaube nicht dass heute jemand
25 Punkte bekommt aber ich glaube die
werden schon teilweise richtig gut sein
deshalb legen wir los mit dem
aufwendigsten mit dem Bolognese Rezept
von Tim Mälzer und aufwendig ist alleine
wegen der vielen Zutaten wir haben
wirklich eine Vielzahl von verschiedenen
Fleischstücken die wir langsam garen
ganz viele andere Zutaten und ich sag
mal so dass es auf jeden Fall jetzt
schon das aufwendigste Rezept aber
Aufwand kann sich lohnen wenn der
Geschmack am Ende belohnt dann ist das
vollkommen in Ordnung deshalb nehme ich
hier einmal den Deckel ab und mache
meinen Bräter richtig heiß der erste
Schritt beinhaltet dass wir jetzt
einfach das komplette Fleisch einmal
anrösten wir haben dabei
rinderbeinscheiben Schweinenacken und
Lammschulter das ist aber glaube ich
eine relativ traditionelle Art und Weise
Bolognese zuzubereiten es wird spannend
ich habe noch nie eine Bolognese wie
diese hier gekocht das Olivenöl beginnt
langsam zu rauchen das heißt ich setze
jetzt einmal kräftig über mein Fleisch
drüber das ist eigentlich kein besonders
weiches Fleisch und deshalb muss es auch
lange kochen zwei drei Stunden stehen in
der Anleitung es geht direkt runter wir
wollen ordentlich Reststoffe Entwickeln
von beiden Seiten anbraten goldbraun und
dann nach und nach rausholen
[Musik]
das Fleisch ist angebraten das hat echt
schon ein bisschen Zeit in Anspruch
genommen weil wir wollten ja wirklich
bei jedem Stück so ein schönes Röstaroma
ran bekommen das lösen wir jetzt vom
Topfboden mit unserem Gemüse also
erstmal zwei fein geschnittene Möhrchen
Staudensellerie eine gewürfelte Zwiebel
und jetzt merken wir direkt Reststoffe
vom Pfannenboden lösen sich während das
Gemüse das Wasser abgibt wenn das ganze
ein bisschen angeschwitzt ist gebe ich
noch vier Knoblauchzehen hinzu auch hier
wird nicht gespart am Geschmack jetzt
noch zwei Esslöffel Tomatenmark das
ganze schön tomatisieren und dann
ablöschen mit 300 ml Weißwein
und den lassen wir jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen einkaufen als nächstes geben
wir 600 ml Rinderbrühe drauf 400 Gramm
passierte Tomaten
und zuletzt unser Fleisch mit dem
Fleischsaft so dass es schön bedeckt für
zwei drei Stunden durchköcheln kann
Lorbeerblätter rein Deckel drauf und bei
mittlerer Hitze garen lassen die erste
Bolognese Köche des wir Zeit für die
nächste und die wird wortwörtlich eine
schnelle Nummer denn sie ist von Steffen
Henssler wir geben erstmal ein bisschen
Olivenöl in den Topf lassen das Ganze
heiß werden kein Weißwein keine
Rinderbrühe das ganze wird quasi eine
instant Bolognese die dementsprechend
auch nicht viel einkochen muss
gemischtes Hack und zwei Feature Bürste
brauchen wir die wir einmal von der Haut
befreien ich habe euch alle
Originalrezepte natürlich auch noch mal
unten verlinkt das ist ganz genau euch
angucken wollt aber die Unterschiede
sind gigantisch allein das ist halt
Feature zum Einsatz kommt habe ich so
auch noch nie gesehen in der Bolognese
also keine Bolognese die wir heute
kochen ist wirklich Standard das sieht
schon in den Topf und anbraten als
nächstes kommt unser Hackfleisch dazu
Rind und Schweinfurt die fifty auch das
Braten wir an gehen jetzt richtig hoch
mit der Hitze der nur eine Chance was da
oben zu bekommen in dem auch nichts mehr
raus das bleibt alles so wie es hier ist
möglichst viel Kontakt herstellen
arbeiten gegen die Zeit und tatsächlich
wir haben nicht so wahnsinnig viele
Röststoffe wenn das ganze angebraten ist
geben wir einfach alles dazu eine Möhre
fein geschnitten drei sardellenfilet
Staudensellerie und Knoblauch
Sardellenfilets auch hier eine
Besonderheit absolut also kenne ich so
auch nicht in Bolognese aber sind halt
geil einfach ne geben einfach Geschmack
sind lecker wir haben jetzt hier wenn du
guckst am Kopf wurden jetzt schon
einiges an Ablagerungen die wir auch
nicht ohne weiteres wegbekommen ich bin
gespannt wie das aussieht wenn wir dann
die Flüssigkeit dazugeben ob das ganze
vielleicht die Rettung ist eine Zwiebel
die wir hier rein reiben sollen nichts
von der Zwiebel verschwenden wir kratzen
das einmal ordentlich aus wir noch mal
ordentlich durch jetzt könnte der Boden
ein wenig geklärt werden schon dadurch
dass wir jetzt auch hier wieder
Feuchtigkeit haben die aus dem Gemüse
Austritt ja ein bisschen Rosmarin hacken
und ab in den Topf Tomatenmark dazu
anderthalb ich gesagt habe löschen wir
das ganze jetzt mit einem Schlückchen
Rotwein ab
es fehlt eine Zutat davon jede Menge 600
Gramm passierte Tomaten
es waren doch 700 Gramm und auf die
rühren wir jetzt einmal unter spätestens
jetzt können wir auch mit der Hitze
runtergehen das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen köcheln 15 Minuten am Ende
abschmecken Pfeffer Salz das war dann
eine echt verdammt schnelle Bolognese
die letzte Bolognese wird jetzt gekocht
die Zutaten sind überschaubar aber wir
brauchen eine Sache die wir bisher nicht
gebraucht haben und zwar eine Pfanne wir
werden nämlich das Gemüse separat in der
Pfanne garen ob das was bringt ob das
ein Vorteil für unsere Rezept mitbringt
wir werden sehen zuerst einmal mache ich
die Pfanne warm mit zwei Esslöffeln Öl
unser Öl ist heiß wir geben das Gemüse
hinein zwei möhren Sellerie Pflicht
Zutaten sind bei jedem dabei das hier
ist wahrscheinlich die Zutat die sich am
meisten von den anderen Rezepten
unterscheidet das hier ist Spitzpaprika
eine Spitzpaprika fein gewürfelt die wir
ebenfalls mit reingeben Gemüse braten
wir einmal schön an schwenken wir durch
eben dann Salz und Chili dran sowie
Pfeffer
Knoblauch noch an gebe ich immer ein
bisschen später dazu also auf jeden Fall
eine farbenfrohe Angelegenheit ist ja
und gibt die Hälfte des Rotweins hier in
die Pfanne zum Ablöschen
dann können wir hier auch schon mit der
Hitze runtergehen drüben ein bisschen Öl
in den Topf geben heiß werden lassen und
dann das Fleisch anbraten unser Öl ist
heiß wir geben das Fleisch hinein
Kontaktfläche schaffen das Fleisch
angebraten Tomatenmark dazu und
tomatisieren Topfboden schön sauber
gehen wir das Pfannengemüse dazu die
passierten Tomaten sind auf jeden Fall
richtig davon geben wir 400 Milliliter
hinein jetzt kommt dazu noch ein
Esslöffel Oregano auch eine Menge würde
ich sagen das Rühren wir ein gehen auf
mittlere Hitze muss sagen das sieht auf
jeden Fall auch jetzt besonders aus 20
Minuten köcheln und dann ist auch diese
Bolognese endlich fertig während die
ersten beiden Soßen schon länger fertig
sind haben wir noch ein zwei Schritte
für die Mälzer Bolognese zu tun wow
guckt euch das mal an oben hat sich
schön fett abgesetzt wir nehmen jetzt
die Fleischstückchen allesamt wieder
raus teilweise und auf jeden Fall schon
schön weich geworden oh ja wie ihr seht
hat mein T-Shirt gerade auch schon dran
glauben müssen es geht alles in den
Schwierigkeitsgrade mit ein wir haben
das ganze jetzt zweieinhalb Stunden
köcheln lassen das Ding ist man kann es
wahrscheinlich auch 5 Stunden 6 Stunden
köcheln lassen zeitlich sind wir ja auf
jeden Fall schon bei einem deutlich
höheren Einsatz als bei den anderen
Gerichten damit ganz die Hände
verbrennen lassen wir das ein bisschen
abkühlen jetzt Zwischenzeit schneide ich
Petersilie kocht das ganze aufgibt die
Milch rein und nimmt das Ganze noch
fertig zusammen Knollen fein schneiden
wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen aber ich
habe das irgendwie entfernt schon mal
gehört dass man das so machen kann ich
meine können wir vorstellen dass es die
Soße sehr mild macht und so ein bisschen
so diese Schärfe rausnimmt die man
vielleicht vom anbraten hat und so das
Video kommt jetzt auch rein genau so ein
wenig Oregano und Pfeffer ja so lassen
wir das jetzt für 5 Minuten aufkochen
mehr als gespannt da zeige ich dir das
nehmen uns zwei Gabeln und machen uns an
die Arbeit gleich hin und zupfen ist
auch noch mal ein bisschen arbeiten ne
die muss wirklich extrem gut schmecken
weil der ganzen Arbeit die wir für die
Bolognese haben zweieinhalb Stunden
köcheln Fleisch klein ziehen rauspicken
Knochen rausholen aufkochen wir machen
das jetzt mal mit dem ganzen Fleisch das
geben wir jetzt wieder rein einmal
umrühren fertig
[Musik]
das ist vollbracht ein ganzer Tag von
Bolognese Kochen geht zu Ende und
endlich können wir die wohl
entscheidendste Frage klären nämlich
dieses Geschmack wir haben hier die
Steffen Henssler Bolognese ich mische
einmal schön durch damit unsere Soße
sich auch verbinden kann geruchlich
insbesondere hier ist das eigentlich
schon recht traditioneller Bolognese
Geruch ich nehme jetzt hier meine Gabel
und wir probieren
überraschende Fruchtigkeit eine gewisse
Säure ist jetzt nicht ultra kompliziert
komplex im Geschmack aber geil komplette
Benotungen allen Kategorien erfahrt ihr
am Ende aber das hier ist schon mal echt
nicht von schlechten Eltern weiter
geht's mit Frank Rosinen als gerade eben
den Topfdeckel angehoben habt ist mir
direkt Paprika entgegen gekommen und ich
muss sagen Paprika kenne ich wie gesagt
gar nicht in so einer klassischen
Bolognese wir mischen auch hier einmal
schön durch dieser Paprika Geruch der
ist wirklich besonders und wir gehen
rein einmal mit Nudeln
boah noch mal gut
du musst auf jeden Fall gleich einmal
probieren bevor wir die das Urteil
bilden kommen wir jetzt zu unserem
Sorgenkind was die Arbeit zumindest
angeht hoffentlich nicht was den
Geschmack angeht die Tim Mälzer
Bolognese obendrauf sehen wir wirklich
dieses Ragout das durch zupfen und noch
mal erwärmen wirklich schön weich
geworden ist das für sich genommen
schmeckt schon echt gut
geschmacklich ne dieses Ragout ist
wirklich aber Oberklasse
trotzdem war das echt eine Menge Arbeit
wenn ich jetzt so nebeneinander esse
frage ich mich ist es die Arbeit wert
kommen wir zur Bewertung ich habe alles
probiert ich habe alles gegessen ich
habe vor allem alles gekocht und kann
deshalb die fünf Kriterien jetzt
bewerten fangen wir an mit der
Schwierigkeit bei Tim Mälzer muss ich
schon sagen es war nicht ganz leicht
auch die Techniken die man brauchte das
Fleisch anzurösten am Ende das Ganze zu
zerziehen und sowas ist vielleicht nicht
für jemanden der zum ersten Mal kocht
demnach würde ich den ganzen drei von
fünf Sterne geben sowohl bei Hamster als
auch bei Rosin war das ganze eigentlich
relativ auf Augenhöhe beides war echt
relativ einfach man musste natürlich
viel schneiden viel schnibbeln auch das
ist vielleicht nicht was für jemanden
der gar nicht kocht für jeden danach auf
jeden Fall schon deshalb vier von fünf
Sternen für beide kommen wir nun zum
Aufwand und der ist bei Tim Mälzer
natürlich enorm im Vergleich zu den
anderen insbesondere mehrere Stunden
kochen köcheln Sachen auseinander ziehen
Sachen im Blick behalten der Aufwand ist
wirklich krass richtig Spaghetti
Bolognese lässt man gerne länger köcheln
aber mit allen Schritten den
verschiedenen Sachen ist das relativ
aufwendig und kriegt damit einen von
fünf Sternen bei Frank Rosin sieht es
anders aus im Prinzip ist das
superunaufwändig weil man geht einfach
ein Supermarkt kauft alles ist glücklich
kocht das ganze wird trotzdem ein Stern
abziehen weil wir hatten diese extra
Pfanne die sich für mich nicht ganz
erläutert hat weil wir hätten es
eigentlich auch in einem Topf machen
können demnach vier von fünf Sternen und
ihr denkt euch vielleicht Steffen
Henssler 55 super easy super schnell
leicht sauber zu machen Eintopf und
alles aus einem Supermarkt Check auch im
Punkt dauert schneidet natürlich Tim
Mälzers Rezept nicht super gut ab es
dauert einfach lange gerade im Vergleich
zu den anderen deshalb zwei von fünf
Sternen Henssler und Rosinen kriegen
jeweils fünf Sterne was sollte daran
schneller gehen du fängst quasi 10
Minuten an bevor du deine Nudeln kochst
und das am Ende eine Bolognese kommen
wir nun zu den Kosten der Einkauf für
die Tim Mälzer Bolognese hat 39 €
gekostet das ist wirklich eine Stange
Geld vor allem weil es günstiger geht
wie wir sehen werden nichtsdestotrotz
sind auch gute Zutaten ich würde dem
ganzen drei von fünf geben weil es halt
nicht super günstig ist auch nicht
übelst teuer und ja irgendwo im
Mittelfeld 3 von 5 Sterne bei Frank
Rosinen zahlen wir 15 Euro für die
Zutaten was schon wirklich günstig ist
gerade beim Hackfleisch kann es plus
minus ein bisschen mehr sein deshalb
vier von fünf es ist zwar das günstigste
von den dreien aber es ist trotzdem
nicht ultra günstig deshalb nicht volle
Punktzahl und genauso bei Steffen
Henssler das hat 18 € gekostet gibt sich
nicht viel gleiche Punkte vier von fünf
Sternen wo stehen wir jetzt also Tim
mälzert von bisher 20 möglichen Stern
neuen erlangt bei Frank Rosin sind es 17
und bei Steffen Henssler 18 ihr merkt
also eigentlich kann Tim Mälzer gar
nicht mehr gewinnen es sei denn der
Geschmack ist so gut dass er alles
verzeiht ich würde sagen für die Arbeit
war das keine volle Punktzahl ich glaube
sie garantiert daran dass sie nicht
genug einreduziert ist ich kann aber so
jetzt nicht mehr als 4 von 5 Sternen
geben ich weiß die Soße kann eigentlich
garantiert noch krasser sein kann also
bewerten was ich gegessen habe 45 die
Rosinen Bolognese war auf jeden Fall
nicht ganz so lecker wie die von Mälzer
fand ich diese Paprika Note war es nicht
für mich
ich würde sagen drei von fünf bei
Steffen Henssler sieht es wieder ähnlich
aus auch da finde ich war das einfach
nicht alles was eine Bolognese kann
warum auch so eine schnelle Nummer die
Punkte gab es woanders auch drei von
fünf Sternen ich muss sagen vom
Geschmack her waren alle drei nicht die
besten Bolognesen die ich je gegessen
habe der Gewinner steht trotzdem fest
Steffen Henssler gewinnt das erste
Rezept Battle der Star Köche danke fürs
zuschauen das war ein anderes Video und
cooles Video schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare ob ihr im zweiten Teil sehen
wollt welches Gericht ich vergleichen
soll und vielleicht auch welche Köche
dabei sein soll bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao ciao